leading the world in domestic terrorist
attacks France okay and of course more
homegrown tears all of the European
victims by the way thoughts and prayers
go out to the family so I'm not saying
this to denigrate them at all what I
actually think that it's a travesty all
of the European victims from brutal
terrorist massacres they are effectively
human sacrifices at the altar of
political correctness so we're going no
I did a segment on on NATO and on down
so of course the surface look at NATO
there's been a lot of talk okay
obviously about NATO the summit London
this last week especially with President
Trump taking a hard line against France
have you guys been following yeah and he
left the summit early Power Move Noah
ran aside Rose of course targeting Trump
let me just say listen I'm while I have
been critical of President Donald Trump
I am a hundred percent with him on this
okay first off the UN is a joke okay
yeah we shouldn't be in it's terrible
even in theory it's ridiculous NATO on
the other hand is a great idea okay
after world war two countries came
together to try make sure something like
that never happened again they needed a
counter threat to the Soviet Union and
unlike the silly completely invalid UN
NATO has only developed into a joke
because of the execution it's the
execution of NATO NATO in theory is
great but what they're doing is and then
it's the French to we have a problem
with yeah of course of course it's a
problem with the French in NATO's and
are we surprised that France is a
problem of international defense they're
the only soldiers who go into battle
with a standard-issue individual white
flag in the so let's go to the first
clip which is kind of they're comparing
I think this is they're comparing Trump
versus macarons comments on NATO let's
just go to clip asked about recent
comments by French president McCrone
that NATO is becoming brain dead he hit
back hard very very nasty statement they
just can't go around making standards
like that about now
in the discounted Trump has had his own
harsh words towards NATO NATO's is
obsolete it's all that's fat sloppy NATO
is old fat and sloppy I love it by the
way the Donald Trump's comments get
bigger laughs bureaucracy riddled with
wet red tape and it's entirely
ineffective see I'm still thinking about
something about Wiley coyote and educate
hunting wabbits I'm hunting web and
Frenchmen it's fat and sloppy that's the
perfect descriptor for NATO and so of
course you have to ever know he tries to
paint Donald Trump is a hypocrite he
doesn't tell you though that Trump and
macron have completely different reasons
okay for being critical that's important
so let me point this out have you guys
been following us a ton no no really
no you get you just follow more so that
the transgender stuff in this any
questions you guys let me know Matt
Graham's point of view here's he's upset
because the United States isn't policing
Syria as as much as they want us to what
happened - we need to get out of other
countries every single time you're an
you're an evil empire okay but we want
you to come in we want you to are we
policing the world it's one or the other
because being an evil empire is
profitable
you just paint there stop policing the
world is spending resources to help
other countries even if they can't
benefit you yeah everyone wants a little
bit more American policing the people
who shouldn't be wanting it are
Americans but I understand why in crap
holes like Syria or France they want our
help
I get it I can't blame them for it but
it's not how we should dictate our
policy so since President Trump has
moved to withdraw troops remember wars
code pink what's good pink Donald Trump
is the first president to actually start
withdrawing troops he didn't just
announce it and say set your date in the
calendar I said did it like Barack Obama
wanna do but he's been withdrawing
troops France they said that we're
compromising their position in the
region so so macron mech Hall is
particularly upset that Trump doesn't
share
the European Union's vision right and he
said that they were there facing the
brain death of NATO because of
differences in vision okay
France is demanding that the United
States adopt a European Union's vision
of NATO and that if they don't they say
it's hypocritical especially we consider
anyway you know if a notification bell
if you have if you are subscribed
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot join my club blood oath credit
outcome slash mud clip because we're
completely demonetised I'll talk about
that moment Ted Cruz the point is this
we don't need to be on board with your
vision for the EU when half of the EU is
vision for the EU let's go this is
another thing you are upset about Donald
Trump's Isis comments when he actually
sat down with President leckrone he did
offer to give France something in return
we have a tremendous amount of captured
fighters Isis fighters over in Syria and
they're all under lock and key but many
are from France many are from Germany
many of them UK they're mostly from
Europe I have that spoken to the
president and hold meeting got as the
French say very uncomfortable
super play
I mean just look at McCrone you can see
from his body language he's trying to
hold himself back but deep down he's
thinking I swear to god this buffoon is
gonna make me cut them that's what you
saw because I saw a little Frenchman
pissing his slacks who the hell cares
what the frig want get my yellow slacks
get my Dockers Lois Levi's I don't care
these two the yellow
the truth is Donald Trump has a point
okay yes you may have exaggerated when
he said that most Isis fighters come
from Europe but macron was certainly
wrong when he said that European
fighters account for a tiny percentage
the truth okay is somewhere in the
middle you know like this surrounded
surrendering Frenchman they're usually
in the middle surrounded by a firing
squad or running away
yes but they can't that's why you form
the circles Oh form the tentacle and you
go and they go I don't know what this
means
what is this fight why so Mexican that's
why we need the wall to keep me out to
keep my impressions upper to 10000
here's a number out of 10,000 Isis
prisoners 10,000 Isis prisoners in Syria
2,000 are foreign fighters now almost a
thousand of those are known at least
known right now to be from your only
crowd think about this for a second
Jesus remember jihadi John yeah yeah how
big of a deal that was yeah jihadi John
it was a net like they were gonna hang
him for treason that was one guy one guy
from the United States went to go fight
for the enemy it was national
impeachment would this is just another
day in jihadi John's yeah about that and
by the way who leaves all of Europe and
Isis recruits mMmmm take a guess take a
guess
I wish we had this some accordion music
or what's the French music I don't know
what it friends I'll give you a hint
[Laughter]
1,900 French nationals join Isis that's
more than twice that of any other
European nation like an Isis factor Wow
and Trevor Noah seasons like look
macarons really confident you've
nineteen hundred terrors ASPs from your
country you have no leg to stand on
because if your stools probably been
blown up I'm surprised that many
Frenchmen wanna fight anyone with a
French passport your muslim been just a
french band table okay it's just
williams-sonoma
was an even more snooty attitude yeah no
no I don't need your new Harry Oh hand
grinder you France are refusing to put
their own Isis fighters on trial okay
they demand that other countries take
care of the terrorists and then they
publicly oppose it when those same
countries sentence them to death for
terrorism this this is why again
they should not be dictating American
policy when we talk about America first
this is a perfect example
sorry France you've let your guys join
the enemy you're not doing anything
about it
you don't get to send them to us or to
any other neighboring countries and then
tell them how they should deal with the
problem we don't cater to France
why because we're better than you now
let me clarify what do you mean better
than I mean take your pick any facet
we're better than whatever is better
economy energy ingenuity healthcare
Olympic medals back at home France they
lead Europe in jihadi terrorism both
terrorist attacks and arrests and here's
a pointer on Trump's critique right he's
been saying for years that NATO members
and this is something we've talked about
and this is what I want I'll get into
the history of NATO a little bit for
people who don't understand why I think
that NATO is important if it were
implemented properly as opposed to the
UN Trump has been saying for years that
countries members of NATO need to pay
their fair share this also
has caused an uproar these grave
security concerns are the same reason
that I have been very very direct with
secretary Stoltenberg and members of the
Alliance in saying that NATO members
must finally contribute their fair share
and meet their financial obligations by
the way he's right as a 20-19 the United
States we are footing the bill for the
entire free world defence you guys were
in the Marines how do you feel about
that it's a waste of money it does seem
like a waste of money I mean I thank you
for your service but it seems to me like
you'd be better served protecting
Americans that you asked like that
that's just too much common sense there
but just a few much be at the border I
think I just heard was melanin riddled
Nazis they're everywhere though to give
you an idea the actual numbers will do
it 60 minutes and Young Turks don't do
by the way happy Congress run change as
a percentage of GDP we lead all other
countries okay and almost none of the
countries even managed to meet NATO's 2%
threshold I think only the UK does
France is at 1.8 percent while we're
over 3.4 percent and in total the United
States spends more on NATO than all
other nations combined oh my gosh well
we have Mexico and Canada we can leave
the rest of the crap to you guys if you
want to talk a little confused as to
what fair share miss it for me no wait
you did 2%
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
when you think about it say okay after
world war two all right you how about
how about we all pitch in two percent
which by the way is like saying hey the
United States you really say you really
saved our ass back there in World War
two so we're all gonna say two percent
because we know that you're really gonna
be concerting one of them but we'll at
least all contribute two percent then we
start contributing three four five
percent Lee can you do the two to me how
entitled the rest of the world is
particularly Europe anyway let's go back
to Mecca home he's mad that we don't
advance the EU agenda he wants Europe to
call the shots when it comes to NATO all
the while France is the number one
source of European Isis fighters and he
refuses to take responsibility for them
I you know what let's go I just I think
that I've I don't want to beat a dead
French horse but let's go to the hole
something does the next clip it's about
trade something with tariffs or
retaliation against new French taxes
targeting us tech companies like Apple
and Google I wanted those companies
they're not going to be taxed by players
I'm not going to let people take
advantage of American companies because
if anyone's going to take advantage of
the American companies it's going to be
us
[Laughter]
Donald Trump is rock and roll man how
dare you take advantage of American
companies that's what I was gonna do
this man is one of a kind he's like the
world's worst superhero no that'd be you
you know you who's not rock and roll
Trevor Noah
if you would be absolutely pummeled by
Drake in a jello fight sir I don't think
you should be speaking for minorities
and late night what happened to taxing
big companies should maybe should they
be pleased tickled pink Democrats to
hear this but really if if president
Trump is all he's saying is that if
American companies are going to be taxed
the revenue should go to the United
States and not France could there be
more bipartisan stance to take yeah
makes [ __ ] sense to me i I
couldn't would aoc be saying hey we
shouldn't have Amazon set up shop here
in New York because we want them set up
in Marseille yeah and then you have an
Isis division yes Isis training is
important regardless is what you think
about the tariffs and the trade wars and
I'm not always on board with Trump with
the terrace but why would you be rooting
for a country that's trying to damage
our economy yeah it's not a partisan
issue senator Grassley Wyden top
Republicans and Democrats on the Senate
they all just released a joint statement
statement saying that the French digital
services tax is unreasonable
protectionist and discriminatory all of
Europe all of the European victims Kay
of brutal terrorists massacres yeah this
and uh you can put men hook for this
okay leading Europe leading the world in
domestic terrorist attacks France okay
and of course more homegrown tears all
of the European victims by the way
thoughts and prayers go out to the
family so I'm not saying this to
denigrate them at all well I actually
think that it's a travesty all the
European victims from brutal terrorist
massacres they are effectively human
sacrifices at the altar of political
correctness that's what's happening in
Europe and a big part of that is because
they don't want to pay their fair share
the reason that NATO exists to get in
the history after World War Two Europe
said we need to make sure this doesn't
happen again and of course they wondered
what would we have to do to get the u.s.
on board
they're the ones who are going to make a
difference and that's when they said hey
United States can we have like an
alliance can we have an agreement and
you know we're not as big as you but can
you give us a hand so this was the
agreement right that these people would
pay certain percentages and so would we
but they aren't they aren't upholding
their end of the bargain and they
haven't been for quite some time many of
them for decades the United States is
entirely blameless with regards to NATO
we are over performing we are over
contributing and we are saving more
lives and well more of the citizens by
the way from these other countries all
the while more of their citizens are
converting to terrorist Islam and
committing acts I wouldn't say
converting to Islam and committing acts
of terrorism and I hope it'll get mad
about that but you know I don't care
they're one in the same at this point of
course not all Muslims are terrorists
but all terrorists it's kind of like
black and bag credit right it's true I
don't know what you're talking about so
they're committing terrorist attacks on
their own citizens in their own
countries and now they're even going to
other countries like Syria to commit
terrorism abroad but just France they
still can't be trouble to spend their 2%
on the problem here's my question
whatever happened to the wealthy paying
their fair share whatever happened with
the top 1% we had all time right
wouldn't government's with trillions of
dollars qualify can you guys open the
coffers a little bit and let's remove
the fact that there are multi-billion
and multi trillion-dollar government's
from Europe and they're not paying their
fair share as viewed through the lens of
identity politics
I don't want France or Germany or Canada
just to pay their fair share because
they're rich and I want to take their
money it's not like some Bernie Sanders
tax plan I want them to pay what they
promised to pay because it's their job
the government's first and arguably only
job is to keep its citizens safe France
Germany Canada Italy they're not doing
that we are so how about this Europe
okay how about this instead of paying
for socialized health care for 12 year
paternity leave in retirement at the
ripe old age of 32 you start doing yours
but ensuring the safety and future of
your citizens it's why you exist it is
your job and Donald Trump is 100%
correct in pointing out that you suck at
it hmm you know what's in here it's just
water that's why they call it acting but
it actually smells garlicky there's
something wrong with the water I think
it's going through the ice maker and we
don't have we don't have the baking soda
in the fridge if you liked this video
subscribe hit notifications or just
check back every single day because we
upload a new video every single day this
is actually taken from the full show a
full hour show the way upload every
single Thursday click that right now go
watch the entire show if you don't want
to you don't you don't have to but if
you if you stop by you know just don't
bother me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic
water